his arrival was unexpected but the Duke
of Sussex fully aware of what makes
headlines as he goes to battle with the
British tabloid press not required to
take the stand but clearly want him to
be seen of making a stand as the
Publishers of the mail fight to have the
case thrown out before it goes to trial
joining him in person in court part of
the joint action the actress Sadie Frost
and Sir Elton John and his Husband David
furnish who allege Associated newspapers
bugged their home taped private
conversations and published their first
child's birth certificate before the
singer had even seen it actress was
Hurley claiming her phone was hacked and
home was bugged with a microphone taped
to her window and that her then
boyfriend Hugh Grant's Car was bugged
the Prince Harry and his fellow
complainants this is personal
allegations dating back to 1993 through
to as recently as 2018 of the criminal
use of private investigators to obtain
medical financial and phone records
allegations categorically denied by
Associated newspapers who say they'll
vigorously contest the claims
Adrian Beltrami Casey for the male
emphasizing the historical nature of the
allegations that the court should not
hesitate to dismiss these stale claims
at an early stage if you have a
defendant with deep enough pockets they
can make good enough offers to transfer
the costs and the risk of that which is
millions onto a claim now Prince Harry
has said he's not going to settle so
that suggests that he's prepared to take
the chance
whether or not the case goes any further
Prince Harry apparently harnessing his
star power to draw attention to what
happens here the poster boy if you will
for privacy in just one of a number of
court cases is involved with that will
be heard in the coming months Katie
Spencer's Sky News